the big premiere of Doctor Strange with
a star that's breaking some big baby
news and there was fierce fashion all
the way around this is Versace yes
you can't go wrong can't really to find
fits they do fine indeed rachel mcadams
stunned in this champagne gown from
Atelier Versace check out the peekaboo
orchid lining and that sexy slit nothing
strange about how effortlessly she
slayed that carpet I was awesome
he's my favorite superhero so I'm super
psyched right now that's blackish star
miles Brown geeking out over meeting
Robert Downey jr. who made a surprise
appearance at the premiere even Doctor
Strange was feeling the love from his
new Marvel family I feel I'm doing it
something like a brotherly son I do I
feel utterly supported and that's great
it means a lot but the big news of the
night Benedict and his gorgeous wife
Sophie are adding to the Cumberbatch
plan baby number two is on its way but
what a 16 month old son Christopher
think of his dad becoming a superhero
you're young to watch a Latino but yeah
it'd be interesting to see who knows
what you make of it but you know yeah
but for me right now it's a wonderful
moment